okay so now we switch gears a bit and
from stable polynomials to hyperbolic
polynomials and our speaker will be
James Henderson from Monash University
okay thanks very much and thank you very
much for the organizers for inviting me
to give this talk so yep today my talk
is called spectra Hedra and directional
derivatives of determinants all right so
what's the the narrow-minded view of
what this talk is about is that I'm
going to be looking at a very particular
multivariate polynomial this is the
thing you get by differentiating
determinants in the identity direction
okay it's some kind of polynomial of
degree n minus 1 in the symmetric matrix
and we're going to see that associated
with this is a very nice convex cone
okay and the main question I'm going to
answer in this talk is whether or not we
can express this convex cone as the
feasible region of a semi definite
program okay as a spectrum it sounds
like a very kind of narrow and precise
question so I'm gonna spend much of a
talking and of explaining where this
question comes from and connect you to
much broader questions and these broader
questions are about the relationship
between certain or conjectured
relationships between families and
multivariate polynomials called
hyperbolic polynomials essentially very
closely related to stable polynomials
okay and these are multivariate
polynomials with certain real rootedness
type conditions associated with these
are nice geometric in fact convex cones
called hypervelocity cones and there's a
you know close relationships and
conjectured questions about how
hypervelocity cones relate to the
feasible regions of semi definite
programming so it's going to be this
background and we'll see that somehow
you know this is a question on the
boundary of what we know about these
relationships
so to get started let me tell you what
hyperbolic polynomials are I mean my
head almost very briefly said this let's
go it more slowly so hyperbolic
polynomial is a polynomial it's
homogeneous of some degree D in n
variables and so it's a polynomial
together with a direction E and we say
that P is hyperbolic with respect to e
if P does not vanish when I plug in e so
number one and number two and this is
kind of maybe the more exciting part of
it is that if I look at my polynomial I
start at some point X in RN and I look
along the direction
e this is a univariate polynomial okay
along the direction
e that univariate polynomial has all
real roots okay so the number of real
roots counted with multiplicity equals
the degree of this polynomial P so just
to give you some concrete example and a
non example just to clarify things so
imagine I take this polynomial and three
variables okay and I consider my
direction to be up this direction up
okay if I start anywhere in this picture
maybe here and I move down in the
picture
I'll intersect this hyper surface where
the polynomial vanishes exactly twice
okay it's a degree two polynomial so
things are good this is a hyperbolic
polynomial with respect to this
direction and no an example is if I take
this quartic polynomial okay so you
should think of this as like the L for
norm ball okay and the cone over it and
if I start somewhere in this picture and
I go in this direction
I mean any direction or in this
particular direction say I'll meet the
hyper surface this real hyper service
twice here's the degree four polynomial
there's two complex roots hiding
somewhere yeah it might be hyperbolic
with respect to a vector on the boundary
of this code nor so because I have its
condition exactly where I mean this this
is this is the surface where this is the
points where it vanishes okay yeah the
answer is no and this is actually it
seems like a technical condition because
actually you need this condition it's an
important so there's no direction this
that's all right so here there's some
examples and okay what's why are these
things interesting from the point of
view of convex optimization that's the
route by which I come to these things is
that we can define a very natural convex
cone associated with these pointer mules
and that is to take all the points in my
space RA for which all the roots of this
univariate polynomial think of this like
the characteristic polynomial of a
symmetric matrix and example we'll see
next are non negative okay so somehow
these are somehow like the eigenvalues
of this point X and I asked for the set
of things which all these eigenvalues
are non-negative it's a very nice and
quite an old result now that amazing
result is that in fact this real
rootedness properties and so on on P
this hyper velocity condition means that
this cone is in fact convex for convex
cone coming from multivariate
polynomials and again if I take my this
example from the previous slide we can
see that you know the hypervelocity cone
will be depending on which direction we
choose up or down will be one of these
nice quadratic ice cream cones also
called Lorentz cone or second-order cone
so that's one example what's fats the
key or the most you know somehow one of
the most concrete and nicest interesting
most interesting examples and when I
take a point Oh me ol P that has what
we'll call a definite determinant or
representation okay so we say that P is
so here I have a collection of D by D
symmetric matrices a1 up to a n I write
this linear pencil with linear
combination of them in variables X I
take the determinant so this gives me a
degree D polynomial in n variables and I
also ask that there's a point E okay for
which this matrix inside is strictly
positive definite so that's where the
definite indefinite determinants or
representation comes so if I had this
sort of polynomial okay this thing
inside is a symmetric matrix so if I
look along any along this direction I
mean I'm always going to get real
eigenvalues okay which is exactly my
hyperbola City condition is exactly
having real roots and the corresponding
high-publicity card in this case is
exactly what we call a spectra Hedra so
the intersection of the cone of d by d
symmetric matrices with some in this
case linear subspace right so
everything's homogeneous I'm only
working with curtains here all right and
these are exactly sort of the feasible
regions of so many different programs so
that's sort of you know a more general
example and if you specialize in various
ways you'll see that you can certainly
get any polyhedron cone out of this by
taking the product of the linear forms
that define faceted inequalities this
forgive me polyhedral cones and again I
need my e to be a point in the interior
of the cone this will do the job and of
course I get the P SD card if I don't
choose any interesting subspace alright
so these are my key examples and so what
I'm going to be interested in as I said
more broadly is you know how do these
hyperbole City cones relate to the
feasible regions of semi definite
programs to spectra here we can see that
any spectra he drawn is the
hypervelocity cones what we saw on the
previous slide and we're also interested
in understanding you know
do we get essentially more things by
considering these hyperbole city cones
or can we really read ascribe any of
these hyperbola city cones somehow in
terms of the feasible regions of
semi-definite program this is kind of
one of the big questions in this area
and we'll push it on this question a bit
more on this talk what why are these
hyperbole city cones interesting in the
context of optimization
what's this result of a ruler that says
that okay I mean not only is this a nice
convex cone okay but it has kind of some
good computational properties all right
so that if I take the negative log of
this polynomial I get a soft concordant
barrier function and the barrier
parameter is the degree of the
polynomial for this card okay so this
opens up the possibility of using
interior point methods to solve conic
optimization problems over these cones
so from the point of view of convex
optimization this is kind of this this
is the point of which convex optimizers
I think started to think about and get
interested in hyperbolic polynomials and
hyperbola silicones and mccoys things
hyperbolic program so of course these
contain some of our favorite conic
optimization problems linear programs
second-order current program so that's
where I have my cone is a product of
these Lorentz cones these ice cream
cones and semi definite programming are
special cases and somehow you know at
the level of optimization a question
we're interested in is you know at least
at some level is hyperbolic programming
more general and semi definite
programming can I do more with
hyperbolic programming than I can with
semi definite programming and it's also
quantitative questions I mean you might
have a hyperbolic program as a nice
concise description but if you want to
describe it using semi definite
programming assuming you can you really
blow up the sides of your description we
still have expect this to happen it's
not level
you know this is a question but so far
the only examples I've shown you are
ones where we already know baked into
the DNA that we can we've only seen
hyperbolic polynomials and hypervelocity
cones that can be described as spectra
he dressed the feasible regions of semi
definite programs so what I want to show
you next is a construction that again
you know came up briefly in markets talk
that gives you new hyperbolic
polynomials and new hypervelocity cones
from old ones in a way that we don't yet
know how to kind of mimic in terms of
semi definite programming descriptions
this is this idea of taking derivatives
if I take a point on your P that's
hyperbolic with respect to some
direction I can take the directional
derivative in that direction so that
gives me a near multivariate polynomial
of one of degree one smaller it turns
out this remains hyperbolic with respect
to this direction why is this true well
it's sort of truth in this picture so if
I think about P along this direction as
being blur polynomial okay if I take the
directional derivative what happens
along this direction is I really just
get the the derivative of this
univariate polynomial and we know that
okay it should have n minus 1 roots
where the one before had n roots and
these roots all interlace essentially
earlier by rolle's theorem or something
we learned in first your calculus so
this is really the proof of why this
works ok and this is a construction I
don't know when this is your first
realized bit certainly in papers from
the 70s about hyperbolic polynomials in
the context of PDEs that identified this
construction of something that works
we're really in the context of
optimization the person who who really
kind of realized this is seemed like a
really interesting construction in the
context of optimization is jim raynor
god sometimes
colles running our derivatives because
of these connections so that's on the
polynomial side what happens on the
geometric side on the geometric side so
this is a picture of in inside here the
spectra he drank this is has this is a
size eight spectra he runs this is
degree eight curve okay in the plane and
when I'm plotting here are the next
curve is the first derivative relaxation
this is what I do when I take the
directional derivative and then I look
at the hyperbola silicon and I can of
course keep doing this so imagine I do
is a few more times and what you see is
that these high-publicity currents they
get bigger this is why I liked we like
to use this word relaxation sometimes to
talk about these things so I think the
derivative of the hyperbola city current
gets bigger you know other interesting
yeah I really
you know the black points I'm not gonna
say anything about them day because I
reused this picture from somewhere else
where they had meaning okay so I can
tell you later but actually this black
point is interesting so one other
comment I want to make is that these
derivative relaxations preserve Loida
mention all faces okay so if you take if
you have some low dimensional face of
your things are like this thing think
about the cone over this object which is
kind of a one-dimensional extreme right
and if you take this first derivative
relaxation it remains an extreme ray
okay so there's a whole lot of
interesting stuff that happens along the
line because of this and if you want to
learn about that I suggest you read
jimin's paper hyperbolic program
programs and their derivative
relaxations has lots of interesting
information about what goes on
okay so let's try to use this to get
some nice new examples of hyperbolic
plurals I mean they're not new people
have known this for a while but new to
us in this talk so for example if I take
the product of all the variables I've
got n variables take the product i'll
collide each n that's the elementary
symmetric polynomial of degree n in n
variables and i differentiate in the all
ones direction what i end up getting is
the elementary symmetric polynomial in n
variables of degree n minus 1 okay and
if i keep iterating this construction
i'll get all the elementary symmetric
polynomials so these are all hyperbolic
polynomials hyperbolic with respect to
the or ones direction they have
interesting hyperbola silicones that are
all somehow relaxation x' of the
orphaned okay with that are you know
really nice and symmetric and have
interesting facial structure that's if i
differentiate in the same direction each
time i get these nice symmetric objects
by differentiating in a whole bunch of
different directions I essentially get
something related to the permanent so
you can get quite complicated objects by
doing this differentiation
if I instead start with the determinant
so I think about the determiner perhaps
is the product of the eigenvalues and I
do this same operation okay if I take
the directional derivative in the
identity direction I get a degree n
minus 1 polynomial and the entries of
the matrix and that turns out to be the
sum of the N minus 1 by n minus 1
principal minors and I can also think of
this it turns out as being exactly the
elementary symmetric polynomial of
degree n minus 1 in the eigenvalues do
all this kind of thing at the level of
eigenvalues of symmetric matrices and
again if I do this lots of times I'll
get somehow that the elementary
symmetric polynomial in the eigenvalues
elementary symmetric polynomials of any
degree in the eigenvalues of a symmetric
matrix these are hyperbolic polynomials
and again the hypervelocity currents are
interesting relaxations of the p SD card
so now we've seen that we get there are
interesting hyperbolic polynomials that
are not obviously not obviously coming
from polynomials that have this definite
determinantal description or if you like
there are hypervelocity cones that are
not obviously spectra Hedra not
obviously intersections of the PSD cone
with a linear subspace so this sort of
now let me present you that sort of the
big questions in this area about how the
hypervelocity currents relate to
spectrum this is conjecture from P del X
this is also again goes back quite a
long way to the PDE literature the the
the conjecture of Lex was that every
hyperbolic polynomial in three variables
has a definite determinant or
representation okay so I can write it as
a determinant of a linear matrix
expression in three variables and this
you know that was a conjecture and it's
now a theorem so the theorem have
essentially held in mini-com but this is
true so if you take any hyperbolic
polynomial in three variables you can
find symmetric matrices a B C so that
polynomial is determinant of ax plus B y
plus C Z
and that you know that's a definite
description so you can find a point so
this is positive different that part of
the conjecture is true and then okay
people have been trying to come up with
a decent generalization of this
conjecture in higher dimensions so you
could try to ask does every hyperbolic
polynomial have a definite determinantal
representation the answer this question
is no all right says various reasons why
you can't have this strong algebraic
statement but there's you can now make a
weaker statement and I'll show you the
difference in a second and you can still
ask this question is every hyperbola
city code a spectra here it's a subtly
different question I'll try to point out
the subtlety in a second and this is I
would say a wider than question not much
evidence either way I'll show you all
the positive evidence in a second so
it's kind of the geometric version of
this question what's the algebraic
version the algebraic version of this
conjecture says if piers hyperbolic with
respect to some direction then I can
find some other polynomial Q so that if
I multiply Q times P that has a nice
determinantal description multiplying P
times P might mess up the hypervelocity
code I mean it turns out if you multiply
hyperbolic polynomials you intersect
behavior velocity currents so you also
need to have this other condition that
hypervelocity current of Q strictly can
tell it just contains the high velocity
for current of P in this case when I
multiply these two things they won't
change the geometric object they won't
change life of velocity cone but they
will change the algebraic object and
they may give us a chance of
constructing this definite determination
so one of the subtleties here is that
you can have you know the same geometric
object with different algebraic
descriptions it's one of the things that
makes the stuff
and just to kind of have one of the
subtleties here highlighted as a asking
for my polynomial to have a definite
determinant of representation is
strictly stronger than asking for my
hyperbola silicon to be spectra he drew
kind of by this multiplier business and
then there's all the business I haven't
talked about much we will come up in a
second that's strictly stronger than
asking that my high velocity car is a
projection of a spectra heat or whatever
that is that will come up just a tiny
bit
so this generalize LexA conjecture is
like again wide open and it's kind of if
you just give me a hyperbola polynomial
you claim to be I'll have a polynomial
it's pretty hard to imagine like how one
would concretely come up with an
explicit spectra Hedra description so
what I want to do is pose a simpler
question but still I'd say wide open
okay which is you know one of the most
interesting constructions we have of new
hyperbolic polynomials from old ones is
this derivative construction so what
happens if I give you a hyperbolic
polynomial and I tell you that it's a
spectra he'd run but the high velocity
kinds of spectra he'd run so I give you
some explicit spectra hydro description
of the hypervelocity code if the lights
conjecture were true would be true that
then if I looked at some directional
derivative I would again be able to find
a spectra Hedra description of this
thing so at least I start with concrete
data and I find a concrete spectra
heater description of this derivative
relaxation if I could do that then I
could find spectra heater or
descriptions of lots of the things we
know and love right every guys so I
don't know how to do this but I propose
this is an intermediate problem that we
should think about but what this talk
the last part of this talk is going to
be about is an easier version of this
problem that we now know is true let me
take an easier version of this problem
as to say suppose I start not with a
hyperbolic polynomial for which the cone
is a spectra here on but with this
stronger description that is a
polynomial that has a definite
determinant or representations that's a
strictly stronger statement so if I
start with one of those what we're going
to show is that what it's shown is that
if you then look at the hypervelocity
kind of the derivative that is a spectra
he drop that's the kind of main result
yes
nor and so we won't be able to do it
twice because because the output is not
a definite determinant of representation
no that's like um how an important point
B is the dominant over the e of B is not
a TT I don't have a proof of that but I
expect the example I'll show you I think
we could show that that would be the
case I'm not 100% sure but I expect that
okay there you go so alright and let me
tell you what we know and that will
maybe answer the question from Cynthia's
observation so this is pretty much
everything that's known about the like
skin all the positive evidence for the
likes conjecture okay so Roman Sagnol
showed and it's kind of implicit in
earlier work but showed that the
elementary the coroner sociated with the
elementary symmetric polynomial of
degree n minus one so the first
derivative of the orphaned if you like
has an explicit spectra heat of
representation of size n minus 1 this
was generalized by pet of Brandon to
show that if you take any of these
currents associated with elementary
symmetric polynomials they have spectra
Hedra descriptions but they have pretty
big size I mean they have size n to the
K minus 1 they're much more recent or
more recently emini has showed that if
you look at certain multivariate
matching polynomials you look at their
hyper velocity cones these are have
bought polynomials and the B's are all
spectra Hedra okay and this ends this
construction sort of I mean contains
these kinds of special cases this is
being quite a lot of you know
development recently in that direction
and then Mario Kumar is also showing
that the specialized vamos polynomials
has something to do with a vamos from a
Troy they did also you know it has a
spectra he drove hyper velocity go these
are lot of the things we know
essentially and then just gain his
number of variables degree is K that's
the size of the matrices or if you in
the spectra heater representation or the
degree of the determinant in the Dermott
determinantal thing so you have to have
multiply is a very high degree to get
this if you like to get this room
so just a quick word on this is that if
we allow ourselves projected spectral
descriptions which is turns out to your
bigger class so it's not just spectra
heater but I'm allowed to apply linear
maps to them a few other things on earth
okay so this coin was understood earlier
in that context in some previous work
with Pablo we showed that all these um
hyperbola currents associated with
elementary symmetric polynomials and the
eigenvalues will have polynomial size
descriptions when you allow for
ejections and then there's also results
that any smooth hyper velocity current
has such a projected spectral
description so a bit more is known here
but you have more to work with you all
right so let me just you know what bust
of a talk give you a bit of a flavor of
what these representations look like I'm
not really going to prove anything
what I'm gonna do is first you show you
what Daniels description looks like okay
and then use that to hint at how ours
looks like for that for the matrix case
so if I want to get a determinantal
description of the elementary symmetric
polynomial of degree n minus one one way
to do it okay is to take the n cycle put
weights on the edges corresponding to
our variables X and compute the spanning
tree polynomial okay the spanning tree
polynomial that is going to be the sum
of all the products of Ages in spanning
trees it's going to give you exactly the
sum of all the n minus one substance
this is not how it's written in Romans
paper but this is there one nice way to
see this for a talk for the picture so
in this case if I took the spanning tree
pollen over this graph I've got the
elementary symmetric polynomial of
degree three and four variables and this
idea generalizes and we sort of know
that you know that if you take the the
reduced because the laplacian has a zero
eigen value edge weighted laplacian of a
graph and i take the determinant of this
thing
excuse me this spanning-tree polynomial
so this gives me a kind of a nice
determinantal description for the
elementary symmetric polynomial of
degree n notes so what does the spectra
he draw description look like well it
looks like I mean this is just looks
like the set of X such that this
laplacian will reduce laplacian is PSD
and the thing i want to point out about
that is what this looks like is I could
write this as V transpose diag X V where
the columns of VV is n minus 1 by n or n
by n minus 1 sorry in the columns of
Eros you know span the orthogonal
complement of the cycle space which is
the orthogonal complement of the all
ones vector so that's the bit that is
going to come out so what's the main
result the main results is to get a
spectra Hedra description of this
elementary symmetric polynomial in the N
in degree n minus 1 in the eigenvalues
ok so this is the first derivative of
the PSD code if you like and that's
enough to get this other a slightly more
general looking statement that if you
take anything with a definite
determinant or representation you take a
directional derivative that that will be
a spectra this is the essential case and
what you do you take a basis for the set
of symmetric matrices with trace 0 so
think of that as the analogue of vectors
that are orthogonal to all ones ok and
you write out some matrix that's linear
in X correspond to these these things
and ask for that to be PSD this is some
kind of natural analog of sango's
representation and turns out that this
works
let's see I've got maybe a minute to
show you a little bit about why this
works to give you kind of a flavor of
why it looks reasonable and then we'll
wrap so in the paper with two proofs of
this thing one is what I call a
geometric proof where I don't explicitly
write out you know an algebraic identity
and I give some separate argument and
what's nice about this is that them you
don't need to be able to know what the
multiplier is and the algebraic argument
this geometric argument the multiplier
sort of it just comes out of it for free
so this is what sort of nice about this
so I just explained it's fine I'll skip
the algebraic argument so this is
another way to write this representation
of Sanyal that we saw a couple of slides
ago is to say that it's a set of X in RN
such that this quadratic form in Y is
non-negative for all Y in the subspace
one orthogonal to all one's that's is a
different way of writing that thing just
rewriting the PSD constraint as a bunch
of non negativity constraints and what's
you know if you had to guess an analog
of this okay I had to guess an analog of
this which I guess I did
what would I choose well I'd say let me
consider the set of symmetric matrices
such that the trace such as this
quadratic form in matrices Y is
non-negative for all Y orthogonal to the
identity it seems like a reasonable
guess if you're going to guess an
analogue okay it turns out this this is
correct the main thing you need to talk
because of all the symmetry the main
thing you need to check is that this
works for diagonal matrices X and the
for diagonal matrices X that gives you
back this does anything you need to
check and to do this you need to use you
know one nice thing you need to use is
the fact that diagonal or the symmetric
matrix is major eyes by its eigenvalues
this is somehow required in here to do
this argument
let me skip the algebraic version but
just to say that if you if you now take
this description and write determinant
of this PSD constraint you would get
somehow what pops out for you is some
multiplier you do this algebraic
identity
there's a couple of questions before I
finish so of course what we've shown is
that the hypervelocity cones
corresponding to the degree n minus 1
elementary symmetric polynomial is the
spectra he'd run we don't know how to
iterate the argument but it's a fair
question
ok these things perhaps these are all
spectra Hedra for all degrees the
smallest example we don't know is the
situation of 5 by 5 matrices and the
elementary symmetric polynomial in the
eigenvalues of degree 3 this is the
smallest example so maybe it's not a
spectra he drew on the Lexx conjecture
spots I don't know one other nice
question I want to highlight that I like
most because of the name is this
question so this this should also be
like if the last conjecture were true
this would be true this question be yes
so suppose I have a permutation in
variant spectra he spectra he drone ok
like the hypervelocity current
corresponding to the elementary
symmetric polynomial of degree K that's
a spectra he drawn I could ask about the
spectral set corresponding to this the
set of symmetric matrices whose eigen
values are in there this is a nice
convex set it's known to be a
hypervelocity cone is it a spectra here
on can I have an explicit way to take a
spectra he drew description of some
vector symmetric sit and build a sort of
matrix symmetric set out of it
so I don't know how to do this fitting
is a nice question all I know at the
moment is the title of the paper ok so
somebody else writes it that would be
great too so it's just have finished so
what have we seen the motivating
questions are now the big level about
this stuff is you know one question is
what's the relationship between this
hyperbolic programming and semi-definite
programming in particular are
hypervelocity cones feasible regions of
semi definite programs ok the main
results in this talk is that ok this new
explicit family of hypervelocity kearns
that come from differentiating
determinantal representations where we
can construct explicit spectral
descriptions a tiny bit more positive
evidence for the Lexx conjecture okay
there's a preprint if you'd like to read
more
thanks very much so we have time for a
couple of questions
yeah just do we believe that maybe the
last conjecture or the lights and
disrespect we hear is possibly fo the
projective not I mean I think oh but
anything could be true I mean that's
what I would say is maybe that there is
another conjecture in this sort of
complex algebraic geometry business was
open for a while which was that any
convex semi algebraic said the
conjecture is that that was a projected
there which projected spectra Hedra so
true in two dimensions true for smooth
things okay this is false o'clock shadow
right sure this was false light last
year and so I you know with this in mind
it's I think completely unclear about
the situation I would not be surprised
if it all falls that would not surprise
me let me know what that imagine - about
dreaming of examples
I guess it's yeah I think it's not and
one thing you have to be to be
hypervelocity kind you need to be
facially exposed for example so in two
basic semi algebraic it's got a lot of
extra properties that are shared by
spectra heater and this is why you know
this conjecture makes sense because we
don't know any of course we don't know
any properly and every property we can
dream up we know about high perversity
kinds of true perspective here
okay let's think
[Applause]